hello and welcome to this video when the
number is wrong let's change it
yes okay so let's go for a Petrov and
White has no he does not play my lines
sometimes it happens okay so then the
some sacrifice is a critical
continuation there should be six
yeah I really have to remember all that
stuff I just studied it
only recently but you still have to
remember at this it's not you don't get
it on the border so here M Bishop III is
the most conventional normal-looking
move after which I will play d5 I think
yeah divorce hanging I mean he does not
have all that many alternatives to hit
one part - yep a bit mysterious the name
let's see what he does
I mean a3 is an alternative but I will
take them I'm a little bit surprised
what I see him actually thinking about
let's check okay hmm
Yanis King d8 is a very tempting move
immediately threatening rook e8 it's
it's too tempting I have to play it
yeah here twin takes comes into
consideration awesome with the tempo on
c3 however taking with the pawn is also
again very tempting as you can develop
the bishop quickly rook e8 is that a
thing and this is probably just strong I
mean if he takes I can't grab some
material and I don't really see why not
castles looks
yeah looks forced and if I grab those
pawns am I really being punished for
that greet I currently don't see I mean
it's you can argue that this is entirely
unnecessary
as I would have had fine position
without the greet but I came yeah I
thought I have the chick and Queen f6
but
it's actually very dangerous
okay I should not have taken that are
already pretty obvious very I mean it
was unnecessary it I kind of I kind of
knew it but it was probably strong
Ruki three maybe I might be too slow him
to cover everything I was such an
unnecessary poor a pretty
it is so tempting you know let's feels a
little bit like some game by Stein it's
from 1880 or so where he tried to prove
that you can grab all kinds of silly
pawns and then defend maybe I'm not lost
to it this am mildly optimistic about
that I could maybe survive maybe ok so
he activates this I still feel tempted
to take you for naught because of the
pawn but simply to give potential
counter play okay but what is the threat
does he threaten much no not so much
what I mean D I have the okay now I'll
take it
and there is Queen d8 which is almost
made but I have Bishop d7 there should
be seven yeah Queen will take on on f7
and now probably c5 my Bishop is playing
way more than I hoped
what the Queen is actually covering g7
are just noise so what what now
Queen d5 would trade Queens I'm a pawn
up and I'm a pawn up so it's probably
not too bad
and then won't get made it
very uncomfortable stuff need the king
on b7 badly but then I should be
reasonably safe
let's see if I can use the king of 2.c4
please oops
just take absolutely everything
okay mmm I've gained quite a bit of time
so the likelihood of losing on time has
diminished a lot maybe I can get the
power No
okay man and it's taking that pause that
was pretty awful yeah I mean here you
have a couple of choices root creator
also thought about but I didn't quite
see the point to insert that yeah so
quintics was that bad yeah d Texas is
probably better yeah that is the most
natural move with this centers know so
castles and now I have went pong rubbing
and it is bad it is really bad
rookie one yeah Queen two before and
this is probably lost him c4 Queenie
three a four a four was the move that I
was concerned about the most pretty
awful this is still extremely dangerous
and probably winning him Group III and
Queen to f6 Luka three he still on the
road to victory here's his sixes forced
Andrew PA daddy five stronger preventing
me from playing d5 and this is already
giving giving up a lot so this horse was
correct
yeah probably would have gone here
you know Jim yeah the worst is over I'm
still in trouble but the worst is over
and somewhere here I'm probably are
getting to be okay yeah yeah it probably
did not play in the best possible way of
it
the time was very short Bishop g2 of
course him or him yeah I had no time I
needed some quickish moves where I
cannot go consolidate and I'm happy to
play such an ending because yeah I know
that I will be able to play reasonable
moves quickly and I'm winning all the
points yeah that was extremely greedy
and I shouldn't have taken all those
pawns that was bad yeah thanks a lot for
watching